yeah we're ready chair thank you
thank you very much um good afternoon
everybody and thank you for your
patience
the committee has considered all the
written evidence of the representations
made at the hearing the committee has
carefully considered the concerns raised
by the interested parties
relating to the licensing objectives of
the prevention of public nuisance and
public safety
however the committee is also mindful of
the fact that no representation has been
made by essex police and environmental
health
and that there is no evidence that
granting this application would
compromise the licensing objectives
once the committee is sympathetic to the
concerns raised by the interested
parties it must consider the applica
application in accordance with the
requirements of the licensing act 2003
the committee has taken into
consideration the applicant's verbal
representations
and the fact that there are conditions
agreed within the police and
environmental health which it considers
will promote the licensing objectives
the committee has noted that the
applicant has indicated that he is
willing to join the
pub watch scheme in rayleigh
and we feel that this will further serve
to promote the licensing objectives in
addition
the committee has noted that the
applicant's willingness to have cctv
placed in the external areas within the
cartilage of the premises
and his willingness to liaise the police
on a suitable placement
the committee has resolved
to grant the premises license subject to
the usual mandatory conditions and
operating
schedule conditions
and the additional conditions agreed
within the police and environmental
health set out in appendix c
and subject to
the applicant joining the rayleigh
public uh pub watch
cctv being provided outside the premises
in agreement with the police
although the committee is aware that the
applicant indicated a willingness to
consider the following
music being stopped at 11 30 pm on
fridays and saturdays
off sale of alcohol not being provided
to walking customers not already within
the premises
there was no evidence provided at the
hearing to justify including these as
conditions to the license no evidence
was presented that linked existing
issues within the high street to this
particular premises
during the hearing reference was made to
deliveries for the premises
but the applicant made it clear that
deliveries would be made via the high
street
in any event it is important to
emphasize that this falls outside the
licensing act 2003
similarly safety concerns raised during
the hearing relating to the proximity of
the premises to the public highway and
zebra crossing fall outside the remit of
this committee
the committee would recommend
oh sorry the committee would remind the
interested parties
that should there be any concerns or
issues arising from the grant of this
licence they may contact the licensing
department to request a review of the
premises license
this concludes the hearing and i thank
you for attending